[موسيقى]
من هنا من قلب الحدث من قلب الدوحه بطوله
كاس العالم 2022 تنطلق اليوم في مباراه
الاكوادور وقطر من وجهه نظر الشخصيه هذه
المباراه
افتتاحيه ضغط الافتتاح ضغط الوجود
الجماهير الكبير راينا ما حدث السعوديه في
كاس عالم الماضي نرجو ان لا يتكرر مع قطر
ولكن هذه المباراه هي الاصعب على لاعبي
المنتخب القطري يجب ان يلتزم الهدوء لازم
يفوته اضف الى ذلك انه ما يتحمس زياده ما
يبادره من الهجوم بشكل كبير جدا لانه
المنتخب الاكوادور حسب ما تابعته داخل
بهدوء ما راح اقامه رح يكثر
في حين انه راح يترك الكره على المنتخب
القطري اللي راح يكون مبادر بالهجوم ولكن
لازم يكون مبادر بحذر شديد جدا المنتخب
سريعه جدا يلعب كره قدم امريكيه جنوبيه
عنده قوه بدنيه عنده قوه المفاجاه وسرعه
المفاجاه وبالتالي على الهجوم او الدفاع
القطري الحذر الحذر الحذر بالتوفيق
للمنتخبين في هذه المباراه وسنرى كيف
سيكون افتتاح كاس العالم 2022 في قطر
[موسيقى]